the opening scene begins 33 years after
Ark fall the time when an alien race
called votan invaded the Earth since
then the landscape of the planet has
been terraformed we are then introduced
to our protagonist Joshua Nolan who is
driving with his adopted alien daughter
Arisa turns out they're looking for
things to scavenge and sell so that they
can afford going to Antarctica which is
now apparently a mystical Paradise after
a while of driving the two arrive at a
wrecked spaceship and begin searching
for salvageable technology soon after
they find a spherical power source
seemingly worth a lot of money but
before they can leave the scene they are
ambushed by an alien gang called Spirit
Riders who take Arisa hostage and demand
everything they have the duo distracts
them and somehow manages to escape but
Arisa is shot in the process as a result
Nolan has to carry her along upon
reaching a safe distance they hear some
strange noises PR prompting them to stop
sensing an imminent danger Nolan quickly
hides the sphere under a broken tree and
takes a cautious measure moments later
they are surrounded by the spider-like
mutant creatures that launch their
attack on them Nolan begins shooting
down these creatures until he runs out
of ammunition as they're on the brink of
being killed a group of sheriffs show up
to their aid and fend the creatures off
following this the father and daughter
are escorted to the nearby settlement
called Defiance which is built on the
ruins of St Louie Missouri currently the
people there are celebrating the
anniversary of the end of the pale Wars
and the founding of defiance which is
now housing a diverse community of human
and votan survivors on this occasion the
mayor of defiance Amanda delivers a
brief speech in which she expresses her
gratitude towards two benefactors who
covered the expenses of this Festival a
wealthy and influential cathan datak tar
and the owner of the mines Rafe mcau
these two folks are Rivals who want to
dominate each other kind of like how
Bezos and musk want to dominate each
other on the contrary datak's son alak
and rafe's daughter chrisy seem to like
each other in the next scene Nolan and
Arisa are brought to defiance's medical
facility where an indogene doctor Ule
treats their injuries while the girl
recovers Nolan is summoned by the mayor
to inquire about their details Amanda
asks him to leave as soon as they
recover but he asserts that they firstly
need to earn money because they were
robbed by Spirit Riders hearing this the
mayor suggests that he go to the Brothel
House as his handsome face will easily
be accepted there later that evening
alak and Christy are seen dancing at a
bar their romantic moment is abruptly
interrupted by Christy's older brother
Luke who strongly disapproves of their
relationship he orders alak to stay away
from his sister but the latter denies
this causes a scuffle between the two of
them but they're separated by christe's
younger brother quent following this
Luke leaves the scene claiming to have
an appointment but he mysteriously
disappears meanwhile with no money and
no equipment Nolan and Arisa attempt to
make a quick Fortune through prize
fighting it turns out that the fighting
arena is owned by datak who makes money
by betting on his strongest fighter much
to everyone's surprise Nolan manages to
defeat the opponent and win a
substantial amount of money however most
of his winnings are confiscated by datak
who alleges that he used an illegal low
blow with no other choice Nolan goes to
a brothel house and sleeps with a
bartender Kenya who is none other than
the mayor's sister on the other hand the
mcau family are dining when they are
visited by Sheriff Clancy he brings the
tragic news that Luke has been murdered
shocking everyone when the sheriff asks
if they have any enemies Quenton
discloses the prior altercation between
Luke and alak casting suspicion that the
latter is the murderer filled with rage
Ag and Vengeance Rafe goes in search of
alak followed by Clancy he confronts him
in a bar accusing him of the crime
however the boy seems to be unaware of
all this and tries to explain that he
was here the entire time just then Nolan
who walks out of a room with Kenya
notices this and decides to intervene he
tries to stop the fight but the enraged
Rafe orders his guard to take him away
as a result a fight ensues during which
Clancy is accidentally shot resulting in
his death before the fight escalates any
further Amanda shows up to handle the
situation she promises to track down the
murderer but ra questions how she'll do
so as the sheriff is already dead right
then Nolan steps forward offering to
take on the task in exchange for good
money the very next day he along with
Amanda and Rafe head to the woods where
Luke's dead body was found upon thorough
investigation of the area and examining
scattered blood stains Nolan concludes
that the Killer is an indogene with a
bound mad left leg hearing this Amanda
recalls her indigene assistant Ben who
said that he hurt his leg last night
without any delay the trio had to
apprehend him and he is currently
planting a bomb on the stasis net he
intends to destroy the generator
powering the shield protecting Defiance
a short while later they managed to
capture Ben but it's too late as the
bomb detonates disabling the town's main
defense system when questioned about his
actions Ben admits that an army of vuler
race are approaching to Defiance with
the intent of destroying the town
sensing the urgency of the situation
Amanda gathers all the town's people to
construct a defense plan as for Nolan
and Arisa they collect their reward and
set off for their envisioned Paradise
however after recovering the sphar from
the woods Nolan has a change of heart
and decides to return to help Defiance
this decision Sparks a conflict with
Arisa who chooses to leave him behind
Nolan then returns to the town and hands
over the sphere to Ule who starts
preparing a huge explosion he then joins
the town's people and takes position on
the cliff aiming at a narrow Canyon
outside Defiance amidst this a man from
cathan race Ela bandic flees the battle
out of fear which leaves datak
infuriated as soon as the vulia
approaches the town's gate the residents
open fire and try to hold them back
until Yu completes the explosive setup
however it's clearly getting hard due to
the overwhelming number of vulia just
when it seems that the town is about to
be overrun Arisa returns leading some
irathient Spirit Riders this earns
enough time for Ule to complete the
setup all the town's people then Retreat
inside after which Ule triggers the
explosion wiping out the entire vulga
force in the aftermath Amanda is seen
resting at the medical facility after
sustaining some minor injuries Nolan
then pays her a visit to report that 41
people lost their lives in the battle
hearing this she says that they must
find out who sent the the vulga and what
they're trying to accomplish she also
hands him a sheriff's badge offering him
to become the new lawkeeper with his
daughter being one of his deputies when
he hesitates Amanda persuades him
pointing out that Defiance is a nice
place to live elsewhere we see a former
mayor Nikki talking with a man named
Birch at a restaurant through their
conversation it's revealed that they're
the ones to Blackmail Ben they wanted
the vulga to attack and Destroy Defiance
for reasons yet undisclosed the next day
Eli is accused of cowardice and is
strung up in the city in order to
undergo the cleansing ceremony a ritual
torture before execution however Nolan
and darisa arrive at the scene and stop
them this infuriates datak the cathan
leader just then Amanda shows up but she
allows the ritual to continue she takes
Nolan for a private conversation and
explains that she can't go against the
religions of the races she then tells
him about a previous incident when the
town officials went door Todo to force
mandatory vaccines on ENT children an
action that killed many of them since
then the town has allowed each of the
eight alien races to practice their
beliefs without human interference Nolan
questions the mortality of this approach
but Amanda asserts that it's necessary
in the meantime Burch infiltrates the
infirmary and wakes up the unconscious
Ben by injecting a substance into his
forehead he then threatens to operate
their old plan related to the mines or
else he'll harm Ben's family on the
other hand Rafe is displeased with his
daughter agreeing to marry alak he
forbids her from returning home unless
she calls off the wedding in contrast
the tar family supports the wedding as
they are planning to secure their upper
hand against the macau's once their son
marries Christie a short while later
Rafe receives a phone call informing him
about an explosion in one of his Minds
this worries him so he hurries towards
the same sometime later noan and Amanda
also arrive at the mine where Rafe
reports that Ben attacked the guards and
escaped underground with 20 kg of
explosive chemicals upon further
discussion Nolan learns that the M shaft
leads to St Louis and that some sections
of the old city are still intact
underground due to the terraforming
folding over it the quickest way to get
down there is to go through a maze of
tunnels with steep drops and razor sharp
rocks called The Rat's Nest despite the
danger Rafe along with some miners
decided to go down Nolan also decides to
join them to make sure everyone is safe
later at Amanda's office Nikki pays her
a visit to inform her that she's going
out of town for some time Amanda then
expresses how she wants to stop the
cathan display in the streets but the
old woman disagrees pointing out that
it's all the alien races have left after
a brief chitchat she leaves in a car
with Birch simultaneously heading
through the underground tunnels the
group reaches Old St Louis on the way
Rafe informed that there's a nuclear
plant underground which must be where
Ben is hiding if it blows up the
radiation will kill everyone hours later
they arrive at the nuclear plant where
they're suddenly attacked by Ben after a
brief gunfight the group manages to
apprehend him despite raf's immediate
impulse for vengeance Nolan reminds him
that they need him alive so that they
can find out who is behind all of this
however Ben provokes Rafe by revealing
that Luke was trying to earn money to
abandon Defiance and his father by
helping him turns out he hated his
father for what he had done to his
mother in this heated moment he throws
himself on raf's gun and pulls the
trigger killing himself outside Arisa
goes to the cathan Gathering and watches
as they place rocks in the basket adding
weight which stretches out ela's body
unable to tolerate this ritual any
longer she climbs up and cuts him down
this expectedly enrages the cathance and
they begin to throw rocks at her just
then another Deputy named Tommy shows up
and fires his gun into the air halting
everyone in order to support Arisa in
her Mission he pretends that Ela is
under arrest for loitering and brings
him to the station for protection a
short while later the Furious datak and
his men walk into the station to
retrieve Ela Amanda also shows up at the
scene and denounces that she's pardoned
Ela from all violations of castan law
not long after Nolan Rafe and their crew
return from the mine and arrive at the
station in the mayor's support this
forces datak to back off for the time
being but he vows to return later Nolan
then reports about Ben's death which
makes the mayor visibly upset in the
next scene a memorial service is held
for those 41 people who died defending
the town from the vulga meanwhile Rafe
struggles to comprehend Ben's final
words regarding Luke he goes through his
son's belongings and discovers Maps a
stash of money and a strange gold object
into indicating that Ben was right
elsewhere Ela has one last meal with his
family after which he departs with datak
he expresses gratitude to his leader for
allowing him some time with his family
afterwards the man is found dead in
front of the Sheriff's Office several
days later one of the residents of
defiance is seen jogging in the woods
during this he is trailed by an unknown
creature that soon attacks him before
dragging him away back in the town Arisa
is approached by a group of spirit
Riders from her race they try to
convince her to join them pointing out
that she doesn't belong in the town
before she can respond she receives a
call from Nolan summoning her to the
crime scene with Tommy once there they
learn that the jogger's body has been
brutally mutilated and the bone marrow
has been sucked clean amidst the
investigation Arisa has a weird Vision
that distracts her for a moment but she
keeps it to herself we then cut to the
Brothel House where Kenya is arousing a
client suddenly numerous spikes rip out
of the man's body resulting in his
brutal death and I thought PE was the
worst that could happen in a state of
panic Kenya contacts the sheriffs who
arrive with Doc Ule upon examination
they discover that the victim was
targeted with pheromones attracting hell
bugs to kill him the Dead Man's tattoo
causes Arisa to have another Vision
leaving her Disturbed she then walks out
and her concerned dad follows her he
seems to be well aware about her
recurring visions and he reminds reminds
her that they aren't real not long after
they find an empty hellbug egg purse
something that one can't find Outside
The Nest this leads them to believe that
someone is behind the hellbug attacks
meanwhile at the tar residence the
family is having dinner with Christie
during the meal datac insults her in his
native language Christie who has been
learning the language understands the
insult and is offended this prompts her
to excuse herself and walk away followed
by alak outside there are startled by
the sudden emergence of Hell bugs
hearing their screams datac comes to
their rescue and manages to kill the
attacking bugs he then escorts christe
back to her place and Rafe thanks him
for saving his daughter shortly after
Nolan and his Squad walk into raf's
house to investigate the bug problem
upon checking if any of them was
targeted they discover that christe's
clothes are sprayed with the phermones
as a results Nolan tells her to burn her
clothes and take a shower to get rid of
them he then begins to question Rafe
about the victims and the latter reveals
that the two dead men had sold land to
him in the past Nolan believing that the
attacks are somehow connected with that
fact asks him for all the paper details
Rafe explains that there was nothing
illegal when he bought the land but the
two men had acquired it from an
irathient family when Nolan sees the
signatures on the papers he senses
something am Miss in the meantime Arisa
experiences another round of Visions
this time focusing on r in one of the
women from the spirit Riders Disturbed
she runs towards a nearby Field to
breathe some fresh air however the
unsettling Visions persist depicting
conflicts between aians and humans when
she starts to panic Nolan approaches her
and calms her down later on the two go
to see sukar the leader of the spirit
riders in order to talk about Ren
despite being initially hesitant sukar
eventually agrees when she tells him
about her Visions this also makes him
realize that she possesses an ability to
see the past the present and the future
without actually being present for the
events sukar attributes this ability to
the irathient god ezu considering irisa
to be blessed he then helps her use her
ability by performing a ritual upon
doing so she is able to access those
Visions more clearly they reveal about
Ren's tragic past her parents who were
murdered by the same two men who were
killed earlier because they didn't want
to sell their land in retaliation she
used her abilities is to unleash hell
bugs on the two men Arisa also locates
the hellbug nest where Ren is currently
hiding out armed with this information
the trio heads to the hellbug nest
located in a warehouse once there they
go down a long shaft via elevator before
heading further inside they wipe the
defecation of the hell bugs on
themselves so that the bugs won't sense
them if there's one thing worse than
Pooh it's bug Pooh and if there's one
thing worse than bug Pooh it's bug poo
from Hell soon after they come across
hundreds of insects nesting at the
bottom along with a really big one that
is probably the queen sukar begins to
search for Ren but she shoots him and
demands the rest of them to disarm
themselves she also threatens to unleash
the hell bugs on them but Arisa tries to
reason with her saying that she has
already Avenged her parents' death
despite this Ren remains unconvinced and
releases the pheromones in retaliation
Arisa throws a knife at her while Nolan
grabs the pheromone container and throws
it at the queen hellbug causing the
young insects to attack her the group
then hops into the elevator and Nolan
detonates the bomb blowing up all the
hellbugs into pieces as they ride up in
the aftermath Amanda announces that the
land that Rafe didn't legitimately own
will be returned to the aians and they
will lease the land back to him this
resolution Bridges the gap between aians
and humans after years the episode ends
with Ren in prison r seemingly accepting
his daughter's relationship with Alec
and Nolan soothing Arisa who continues
to experience unsettling Visions while
sleeping subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching